Good morning, and welcome to this first cachexia session of the
2026 AACR annual meeting. I thought I would
just ask you to
maybe take a picture of that QR code if you wanted
to
ask your question on the computer.
So I'll give you a few seconds to do that if you wish.
And of course, instead, you could always just come up to the
microphone. They're asking that you come to the microphone for questions
in order for the questions to be heard by everyone online.
Are we in? Okay.
So welcome to this educational session on the biology
mechanisms and models of cachexia. I'm Teresa Zimmers.
I'll be chairing this session this morning.
So cachexia
literally means bad condition, and it is the cause of death for
many people with cancer. It is the physical
manifestation of treatment resistance, and it is the
reminder of the mortality that's driven
by cancer.
A useful definition is that cachexia is a tumor-induced
systemic derangement that leads to changes in appetite and food intake,
abnormal immune response, and dysmetabolism.
And altogether, this leads to tissue wasting, dysfunction, body weight
loss, and then death.
Clinically, it's diagnosed as weight loss over the preceding five
months or less weight loss in someone with pre-existing low muscle
mass.
Cachexia or weight loss is
very frequently the symptom that drives people to seek a doctor's help,
and indeed, it often precedes a diagnosis of life-threatening cancer,
as shown here in this very large study that
weight loss of greater than 5% was highly associated with
a diagnosis of a deadly disease.
And cachexia, as I said, is a physical manifestation of a
treatment-resistant state, chemotherapy reduction, surgical
mortality, and importantly, immunotherapy response or
failure for immunotherapy response, such that cachexia is a stronger predictor of
mortality than age, stage, or performance status in this
study of non-small cell lung cancer patients.
There at this time, despite intense research, limited treatment
options for cancer cachexia.
But there is hope and there is progress.
And today in this educational session, we'd like to take you on a journey from the
very smallest Drosophila models of cancer cachexia.
We'll learn about the biology of cachexia from Tor Erik Rusten from the
University of Oslo.
I'll be speaking about some of our findings of systemic reprogramming
in cancer cachexia using mouse models and patient biospecimens.
And then Mohaned Abou-Ramalah from Dana-Farber will be
speaking to you about a molecular axis all the way from
mice to patients. And so without further ado, I
invite Tor Erik to the podium.
Well, thank you, Teresa, and thank you, AACR, for the invitation.
So before I start talking about mechanisms involved in cancer cachexia, I would
like us to reflect a bit more about tumor host biology.
So this is a cell, the way I see it. We are consisting about 30
trillion of these cells of different kinds.
They all come from the same kind, but
they work for the most part without failure for the most of our life.
Their instruction is, of course, written in DNA, and we all
here agree that it's change to this genetic code that starts
some of these cells on the path towards
tumor genesis and eventually cancer disease.
We know a lot about these changes that start cancer development,
but really what we know is mostly about this cell here, which is the cancer
cell. When within the tumor, we know that we have different
cancer cells of different genotype and different non-tumor cells as well.
This is again, often a part of an organ that resides in body fluid
flushed with nutrients and signaling molecules that affect its tumor development.
We know that tumor cells can either combat tumor development or spur
further progression.
So this is more what it looks like. These green tumor cells here interact with
these
red immune cells, and this immune cell here has eaten a
part of the green tumor cell, and this is non-tumor epithelial cells.
And by the way, this tumor is from Drosophila, the fruit
fly.
Again,
we know that this is a part of the organ system that makes us up, and we
know that nutrition both affects the
number of cancers
being developed and how cancer progresses.
We also know that the tumor interaction with the neighborhood and
distant organs is bidirectional.
And today we'll talk about how the tumor wreaks havoc with distant organs,
but we'll also talk about how distant organs affect tumor development.
So we're interested about the tumor host interactions
in general, both locally and distant in my lab.
And to address these questions, we use Drosophila, and I'm
sure you all have this question. Why do we use a fly to address these
questions?
So Drosophila is an animal like you and me.
It has a bilateral brain. It has an elementary canal where stem cells
replenish the gut lining. It has a primitive kidney.
It has muscles, has adipose and liver tissue.
And in this female fly, you have the ovary, and you have patrolling immune cells
that you just saw in the confocal image.
And in this situation, in this physiological condition, we can see the tumor
cells just like you do in mice and address the question:
How do these tumor cells interact with the systemic
organs and physiology of the fly?And in
flies, many labs, including our own, have developed models in
which to study cachexia, so how the tumor breaks out with the
different organs of the body, and their physiological consequences, and they're
listed here. We have a model of gut carcinoma developed by the Periman Lab,
ovarian carcinoma, and uroepithelial carcinoma, and also allografts we
can do in flies, just like we do in mice.
I just want to summarize a whole body of work from many labs, including David
Bilder, Norbert Perrimon, Wu-Min Deng, our own
lab, Lewis Chang, and many others that have used flies
to address the question of how
muscles are wasted and how adipose tissue are wasted in these models.
And by and large, they concur with the studies that have been done in
mice before. So the reduction of insulin signaling, induction of
autophagy,
IL6 and TNF signaling is involved in
wasting of these tissues. And in yellow here, I've
listed the findings that have been initially found in screens and studies
in flies that had been then translated into mouse.
So you can start with flies, and you can find out what
is working in cachexia in mammals.
And here is one notable example where
orexigenic
feeding controlled by NPF is controlled by inflammatory signaling and
insulin signaling in the fly and also in mice.
But we believe that the paraneoplastic effect of
the tumor goes beyond muscle and fat wasting.
So the results from flies also then translated to mice have
shown that there is a
blood-brain barrier leakage in these cancer cachexia models, both in
flies and in mice.
There are kidney failures resulting from tumor
presence, and there is systemic coagulopathy.
And all of these conditions shorten lifespans.
So I think we have a lot to learn about how cachexia shortens lifespan.
All of this is summarized in the review we just published.
You can learn about how physiology of the fly and mammals compare,
and what findings has been done so far.
So for the remainder of the talk, I'll focus on this cancer model shown here.
So here you have a confocal image of a brain and the uroepithelium where
we make these clones of transformed cells.
Here is a benign Rasv12 condition where we have these clones
developing. When we combine this with a tumor suppressor called
scribbled, this developed into full-blown cancer with all the hallmarks that you're
so familiar with, including Warburg reprogramming
of metabolism and cancer cachexia like organ wasting.
And you just saw how the tumor in red here developed and enveloped the
brain and migrated into the brain in this condition.
This is a very good cancer cachexia model.
Our studies of this started really by the interest in finding out
what the process of autophagy may be doing in the cancer situation.
Autophagy, as many of you may know, is the enveloping of
a part of the cytoplasm. It can contain organelles, protein
aggregates, or general cytoplasm, where these organelles are
shuttled to the lysosome for degradation and
reusing the
nutrients that were made, amino acids,
lipids, sugars, and nucleotides.
It can be locally within the cells or shuttled to other parts of the body.
So what we found a number of years ago was that when we had
malignant cancer clones, shown here, the Ras Scribble clones,
it induced autophagy stress response with this autophagy marker shown here
surrounding the tumor. And we could show that this autophagy stress
response in neighboring cells is required for the growth of
that tumor, and initiation was governed by TNF alpha and
IL6-like signaling in the tumor cells.
Now, in that study, we also found that the tumor
induced a systemic stress response of autophagy
in the relevant tissues that we are just talking about, in muscle, in gut,
and in the fat. And moreover, if you take tumors
from
animals that are completely lacking autophagy, the tumors don't grow in
that situation. But when we take those tumors and transplant it into
adult wild-type host, we can make them regrow.
But they don't grow if you put them into a host that is defective in autophagy.
That already told us that autophagy is somehow promoting
or supporting tumor growth from the host.
So in addition to this observation that you see here, you see this white
tissue here, which is the adipose tissue, withers away as the tumor
grows. We got the idea that perhaps this is a good model to start studying
cachexia. And this was at the time that Norbert Perrimon and David Bilder also
started studying this in the adult fly.
And so we asked our own questions. Can organ wasting
occur by autophagy? Are flies a good model to study cachexia, and
does organ wasting contribute to tumor growth?
And so, we teamed up with Todd Schoberg and Nasser Rouzbeh's lab
at NIH, and we used micro CT scanning and
3D rendering of animals and looked at how the organs fared
when the tumor grows. And on the right-hand side, you see the red tumor grows
over time, whereas the systemic organs degrade.
And you see the blue adipose tissue here and the muscle
system quite elaborate, but it degrades over time.
The same is actually also true for the gut and to a limited degree
for the kidney.
We could further show, and this is published, I'll go through this fast, that
the adipose tissue withers away,
that this single muscle fibers withers away
as the tumor grows. But when we take away autophagy in the whole animal, this is
protected. We can bring back autophagy in the tumor and the
immediate microenvironment, and that brings back tumor growth somehow, but then
still the systemic organ wasting is protected.We
could further show that the result of organ
wasting through autophagy is mobilization of nutrients
flushing into the Drosophila bloodstream to the rest of the
organism. So we asked this question
whether
tumor growth, in this case, in this cachexia situation,
is governed mostly by building blocks from the food
coming into the animal or whether it comes from the degrading organs.
So we devised our own stable isotope
measurement protocol in order to address that question, and
since this is published, I'll go fast through that here.
We could show that most of the biomass of the growing tumor in this cachectic
situation actually derived from the degrading organs and
not food.
And so we have the situation here where we know that the tumor
induces a response in the systemic organs.
We know that the systemic organs somehow support tumor growth.
This could be signaling molecules, it could be nutrients.
We're interested to learn what those are.
And to do that, we have actually developed avatar systems now where
we can use the whole genome tools available in flies
to manipulate any given organ using the Gal4-UAS
system. There's a Gal4 transcription factor, then UAS target genes for any given
gene. And we have developed a way to make tumors independent on
that using a similar system with
recombinase-driven clonal development and
using the QF transcription factor and designing different
tumors. This is how it looks in cartoon form.
It actually looks very similar when you look at animals, and immediately you can
appreciate that you can look at organs, organ size, how they fare,
and tumor size in these situations where we can do screens.
So we have been doing screens for interactions of these tumors
and the immediate epithelium microenvironment
with the immune system that you see here, and also
how the tumor
communicates with the rest of the body to govern tissue wasting.
And we have identified some of those that we are now mechanistically
identifying.
But what I want to use the rest of the talk about today is to talk about one of
these other yellow blobs here. What is transferred
from the host to the tumor in order to affect
growth in this cachectic situation?
So I already told you that autophagy mobilizes nutrients of
different kinds
to the circulation in this cachectic model.
So we asked the question, are any of these nutrients necessary
for tumor growth
reciprocally to organ wasting?
And we cannot stop nutrient mobilization specifically, but we can stop the uptake
of these nutrients into tumors. You may know that all these nutrients are
polar, so you need polar
transporters that transport these polar molecules across the membrane.
These are called SLC molecules. So we took out each of these SLC
molecules at the plasma membrane in these tumor models and asked the question,
which of these SLC molecules are required for
malignant tumor growth, but not benign Rasv12 growth or
normal development of these epithelia?
So we identified one that behaved exactly like this, which is called
subermesa in Drosophila, and you see that this
reduces tumor growth, as does these other amino
acid transporters. But only subermesa behave in a way
that it reduces malignant tumor growth, does not affect a
benign Rasv12 growth, or does not affect normal development of
cells that have subermesa knocked out. So what is subermesa?
Subermesa is most similar to the two nutrient
transporters, SLC7A11 and SLC7A9 in
mammals.
SLC7A11 is kind of like a superstar in the
cancer field. You may know that SLC7A11
imports cysteine, so the oxidized form of cysteine into
the cell.
Cysteine is reduced to form cysteine that can be
combined with other building blocks to make glutathione
within the cell to provide reductive power.
And the enzyme GPX4 is used in glutathione to
detoxify peroxinitrosated lipids that
are produced in transformed
cells, often by
high metabolism.
If this doesn't work,
these transformed cells die from ferroptosis.
So iron-dependent cell death. There is a
similar nutrient transporter called SLC7A9 that is known to be
required for cysteine re-uptake from urine in the kidney.
And so we were interested to go further along this way since we know that these
tumors that we study have very high ROS produced by
mitochondria.
And so we looked at these ferroptosis
markers, which is 4-Hydroxynonenal, a lipid aldehyde that
is produced by this lipid peroxidation.
Also a direct marker, a lipid marker that fluoresces upon
peroxidation. We see in both these situations, although
tumors do have high ROS, they do not show signs of
ferroptosis. They show signs of ferroptosis only when you take away
subermesa. So that protects against ferroptosis in the fly model.
We can rescue this by providing subermesa back into the fly.
It both rescues ferroptotic markers and tumor growth.
And so then next we asked the question, does this compare to
SLC7A11 or A9 in the mammalian system?
So first we modeled it using AlphaFold and a predicted
structure of subermesa in the fly and compared it to either
SLC7A11 or A9. We could see that it's more
similar structurally when modeled to A9 than
A11.Similarly, we could model it and see that
it fits the human partner,
CDA98, which is a chaperone that
shuttles it to the plasma membrane very well.
So then we asked the biological question, can we put these
human potential orthologs into the fly and see whether they
rescued the ferroptosis and tumor growth in the fly?
And we could see that SLC7A9 readily could rescue both
ferroptosis and tumor growth in the system, whereas A11 could
not.
The wrong way. Let's see.
Sorry about that. So then next we asked the question, since
SLC7A9 seems to be the counterpart of subermesa in the fly, we
asked the question whether A9 has a functionality in pancreatic
cancer in mammals. So first we looked at using
DepMap, looked at the expression levels of SLC7A9, and found that it
was expressed similar to A11, so it's increased in
pancreatic cancer, as is NRF2, which is known
to be upregulated and used by
pancreatic cancer cells to fight off ROS,
as are enzymes used to make glutathione, and the
enzyme that uses glutathione to detoxify lipid peroxidation.
So then we asked the question, if you take out A11
and A9 in pancreatic cancer, how do they compare in
functionality in that system? So what you can see here
is the growth curve of a pancreatic cancer cell line, HPAF-2, but
this is also true for other pancreatic cell lines.
When we take out SLC7A11, we can find, like other people have
shown before, that it reduces
growth of these cells. If you take out SLC7A9, it
also reduces growth of these cells, but they do not affect
normal cells, which is HPDE
line, which is shown here. Both are required for keeping
glutathione levels high within the cells, and both are required to
fight off
ferroptosis markers in these cells.
So SLC7A9 is working alongside
SLC7A11 in the system to import
cysteine, generate glutathione, and fight off ferroptosis.
We think this is fighting off ferroptosis because we can rescue
SLC7A9 just like SLC7A11 by
either reducing lipid peroxidation
by adding liproxstatin or directly adding
glutathione to the cells. That helps them fight off lipid
peroxidation.
So then finally, we asked this question in
the mouse by
transplanting xenografts into the pancreas
of stable knockdown cells for A9 or A11.
We see that A11, like people have reported before, have a slight reduction of
growth, but it comes back. A9 actually has a
stronger effect on growth than A11 does in our hands,
and they both have markers of ferroptosis in those
tumors.
So does this have anything to do with autophagy that we started
out with? So if you look at levels of cysteine in
circulation, so we did targeted metabolomics to look at this, we could see
that as the tumor grows, there is an increase of cysteine in circulation
in this model. If you take away autophagy in the whole animal, you
see that this
mobilization do not occur. And if you look at the ferroptotic
markers in the different situations and permutations with tumors,
we see that in the RasScribble tumors, we do not have
ferroptosis. If you look at the autophagy background
animals, where autophagy is taken out both in the tumor and in the
host, we see the appearance of ferroptotic markers specifically
within tumor cells and not neighboring cells.
Whereas if you take away autophagy in the tumor itself, there is no ferroptotic
markers.
And so,
then next, of course, now this question is, is
cysteine and glutathione limiting for these tumors in the system?
So when we look at
the animals that are autophagy deficient, where you have
ferroptosis going on, and we feed them orally
N-acetylcysteine or glutathione to replenish or increase
the circulatory availability of cysteine, we could
reduce ferroptosis. We could also
reduce ferroptotic markers when feeding glutathione, but not
N-acetylcysteine when we knock down the
subermesa or SLC7A9 in flies, probably
suggesting that N-acetylcysteine is transported
through subermesa in the system.
And the million-dollar question is, of course, does this not
only fight off ferroptosis, does it also affect tumor growth?
And yes, it does. So the
feeding of N-acetylcysteine and glutathione in the system
not only fights ferroptosis, but it makes the tumor rebound.
So I hope I convinced you that using the flies have been
a good model in which to ask the question,
how does the animal
lead to organ wasting, and does organ wasting reciprocally
affect the tumor growth? And in this case, we have identified an amino
acid, a metabolite, that is mobilized from
systemic tissues to help the tumor growth, not as a building block, but to
fight off cell death.
Thank you. I'll stop here and take any questions.
Beautiful talk, Tore.
I have a question about the chaperones and the localization during the tumor
development and also
the question about the chaperone there as well, as
it works with the ceremessa. Could you reflect on that a little bit, whether
that's regulated?
Yeah. So what they call the chaperone, the CD98HC, is an
obligate partner of the whole SLC7
family. So when you take that away, the tumors don't grow, but we don't know
which member. But obviously this is a good
candidate for the specific one
for transport. So CD98HC is required for
SLC7A11 to act as a nutrient
transporter at the plasma membrane.
So does the transporter itself change localization
during the tumor development in the fly system?
Yeah. So we tried to look at that, so we tagged the proteins, but as you know,
these cells are really small, so it's a bit hard to look at their localization.
So we need to look at another cell type in order to get at that, I
believe, or do immuno EM.
Thanks.
Yeah. Good point.
Thank you very much. I'm a clinical oncologist, and I've been always convinced that
cachexia is what is killing patients, actually, not the tumor itself necessarily,
but it's that cell death mechanism that happens in every normal tissue,
especially endothelial cells. When you kill the endothelial cells, you're going to
get a huge PE, pulmonary embolus, because there will be no more protection against
clots. But I was also told that there's a time to
initiation of autophagy, meaning normal
cells can tolerate some deprivation of nutrients before they
start. Is there an agreed upon how much time?
Because I'm thinking if we replenish, but we need to replenish before the process
starts in the normal cell. So what is the time of deprivation
of nutrients before the process starts in a normal cell?
You're asking different questions here.
So yes, it's true that it takes time for autophagy to
be initiated in response to starvation.
Mm-hmm.
This is normally 12 to 14, 15 hours perhaps.
But autophagy is controlled by so many other stressors than
nutrient-
12 hours, really? Hours or days?
Hours.
Yeah.
So in 12 hours, if you're not eating, you start having autophagy?
Yes.
Mm.
And even earlier in some tissues. So some tissues are more sensitive than others.
These are results mostly from mice, so metabolism
is different than
in humans.
But I should say that autophagy
activation is controlled by so many other stressors than starvation,
and I think that's what we're looking at here.
So it could be inflammatory signaling. It's controlled by FOXO.
It can be controlled by ROS, et cetera.
So we actually don't know what is inducing autophagy in all of these
contexts. In this model, it seems to be a reduction of insulin signaling by these
secreted insulin growth by adding peptides called input in flies or
IGFBPs in humans. That seems to be central both
in flies and in mice and possibly humans.
Has anybody looked at tumors at the very end of the fight in a
cancer, meaning at the late stages of
the fight-- Not late stage, like stage four versus stage one, but rather in
pre-death versus in the same patient early and ask what is the autophagy
difference? Is there autophagy difference in these tumors?
Autophagy machinery abnormalities, let's put it this way.
In the tumors?
In tumors, yeah.
Yeah. So a lot of people have looked at autophagy and its role
in tumor development. This is not work by us.
This is work by Aileen White Fenton and Alec Kimmelman,
Jay Debna, et cetera. So
on the top of my head, I don't recall all of those answers.
Yes.
Any questions?
That's a beautiful talk, Tore. I was wondering,
for all of the different kinds of Drosophila tumors,
do you think the mediators are the same?
Are the pathways at the end the same, or are there tumor type
specific differences,
which is something we think we might observe in patients.
Yeah. So the question is, do all tumors induce
cachexia, organ wasting, and other effects in the same way?
My personal guess is that it is not.
I think there is overlap, but there's probably differences also, and this is what
we're trying to find out at the moment.
Thank you.
Are there any other questions?
Okay. Thank you so much, Tore.
So thank you so much for coming this morning.
It's great to see so many new faces in the cachexia
interest community.
The work I'm going to talk about today is primarily funded by a program project
grant by the National Cancer Institute on the macroenvironment of
pancreatic cancer. The program director is Dennis Guttridge.
The other PI is Mike Ostrowski, and Lenny Coneyars and I lead the
projects at Oregon Health & Science
University with some wonderful postdocs, Ashok Narasimhan, who's
actually in British Columbia, Brittany Counts,
students Sephora Zhan and
Sarah Ota,
in collaboration with Hyun Ro at Indiana University, Shaokai Chi
Zhang, and Tingbo Guo, who have done a lot of computational
interrogation and discovery for us.
So the current-The paradigm of cachexia, as you've heard, is that there is this
wasting syndrome that results from the tumor, and it's really signals
from the tumor that are signaling on the peripheral tissues to
activate this wasting, and that's partly through anorexia, and that's certainly a
component of it,
but also through active catabolism.
And the mechanisms that have been most intensively studied are systemic
inflammation, and this is both cellular inflammation, activation of
macrophages, and also the expression of various
inflammatory cytokines leading to altered metabolism
in all of the tissues that have been examined to date.
And as I said, this happens in part through effects on the brain, inflammatory
cytokines, reducing appetite, altering tumor metabolism
and liver metabolism. And in fat and muscle, which we'll be looking at today,
it's really been attributed to lipolysis and
remodeling of adipose tissue, along with muscle wasting induced
by an imbalance between protein synthesis and protein degradation, which is a
combination of autophagy and ubiquitin proteasome pathways.
And most of this information that we know about cachexia, and I would argue almost
virtually all of it, actually comes from animal models, including mouse models.
And so what is really truly known about people is another
story. But like this review from
Tobias Janowitz's group in "Cell,"
that the clinical picture also demonstrates inflammation followed by some degree of
dysmetabolism. The evidence for this, I think, is less than for inflammation, which
leading to wasting, treatment resistance, and death.
So,
there's a lot of question these days about how well our animal models actually
reflect human disease. And indeed, there was recently a paper in "Nature" that
suggested that rodent models are actually not very reflective of what happens in
muscle in patients with pancreatic cancer and colorectal cancer
cachexia. So we decided to test this directly, and we're comparing
transcriptomes from patients with pancreatic cancer versus our mouse model
of orthotopic pancreatic cancer that progresses over
time.
Our patients
had biopsies taken at surgery, so they're all definitionally early-stage
tumors. And they're significantly different from the control patients
for weight loss and weight change, and weight loss grade, and
myofiber cross-sectional area, and not different for sex,
BMI, or actually total skeletal muscle or total
adipose.
And if we compare these patients
to controls, a case-control analysis, we don't see very many differentially
expressed genes. They tend to be sex-specific and not very many are
overlapping. Some of these pathways have been implicated in mouse models.
But it got much more interesting when we took all of these data and did a weighted
gene-centered network analysis accounting for all these different variables.
And what we found is that the networks that are most
strongly, significantly different associate to weight loss
grade at one month. So acute changes in the body, which makes
sense to me.
And when we look at those, and we look at those pathways in those three modules and
the hub genes, it actually looks very much like mouse models.
So everywhere there's an asterisk here is a pathway that was
discovered or defined or interrogated in
mouse models and likely fly models as well.
So there is truly, at this level, a substantial amount of
overlap.
And so this is our mouse model of cancer cachexia.
It's an orthotopic implantation of a very aggressive pancreatic tumor line.
The mice lose weight over time. They lose fat mass.
The individual muscles and fat pads are lost.
If there's inflammation, they get splenomegaly, and we get loss of liver and heart
mass.
And if we look at the transcriptomes over time, it actually is revealing.
It's not just a long slide to
death. There's actually some interesting temporal
changes. And from a molecular perspective, when we
interrogate metabolism pathways and from if you look at actually the
trajectory of weight loss, you see that there's this early acute shock phase
followed actually by a compensatory plateau not only of weight but of gene
expression. And then there's indeed a slide into a
terminal wasting phenotype. I'm not going to talk about the metabolism aspect of
that today, but it made us think, if this is what's happening in
mice, where are we capturing our patients?
We don't think we're capturing them here.
And so comparisons that have been made to date are really looking at end-stage
mouse models and early-stage patients.
So if we actually then look at our cohort and we stratify by one-month
weight change, and we look at gene expression profiles, would we see
something that we wouldn't otherwise detect?
So this is what we did. And in males, we have about 2,000 genes that
correlate with acute weight loss, and in women,
2,500. And there's substantial overlap with our mouse
model.
And indeed, if we look at a heat map here, there's actually quite a lot of overlap
between mice, women, and men with pancreatic cancer.
And the majority of these are negatively correlated.
That is, they increase with body weight loss.
And a fraction of them are positively correlated, genes that decrease with weight
loss. And then, it's these positively correlated genes in mice that
are less reflective of what happens in people.
But it gave us more confidence that we are using a model that's potentially
clinically relevant. And that's important because we have, and
others, have done clinical trials based on things that we have discovered in mice,
very similar to most other cancer research context.
And if we look at some of the pathways that have been most intensively studied in
mouse models, like the ubiquitin proteasome, and we look at these skeletal
muscle-specific ubiquitin ligases, TRIM63 and
FBXO32, we actually see that there is some
degree of correlation to weight loss, not only in mice but
also in patients, and they might be different between sexes.
And if we look at inflammatory pathways, and this is one that's been of particular
interest in our lab for years, the interleukin-6/STAT3
pathway, that we also see strong correlations, not only in our mouse
model but also in our patients. So again, pushing
back on this idea that our rodent models aren't reflective of what's happening
in human disease.So then to ask what's happening
in the muscle microenvironment, we did some single nucleus
RNA seq studies. So this is in our mouse model. It's done at day 12.
The mice don't have overt cachexia yet. It's an early stage.
And we're already seeing some pretty profound differences in the muscle
microenvironment, including an expansion of myonuclei, a reduction
of fibrogenic/adipogenic progenitors, and some changes in immune cells.
But I want to focus on the myonuclei today, and what we see is that there's a
real identity shift in these cells.
So this red block of cells are myosin heavy chain 4, high
MafH cells, and they really turn into
a group of cells that actually have different
expression profiles. And what we see in the pseudo bulk and for the
myonuclei is that we have a loss of myosin heavy chain 4, and then
interestingly, we have a loss of this transcription factor, Maf.
And Eric Olson's group showed that Maf is actually a master
transcription regulator of muscle maturation.
So Maf comes up at about two months in mouse development, when myosin
heavy chain 4 expression is established, and after myosin heavy
chain 2 and 1 have receded. And then if
you delete Maf, you reduce myosin heavy chain 4 expression, and you
have hypotrophic muscles.
In our cachexia model, Maf declines over time,
and you can see the targets of Maf, which are shown here, also
declined, and myosin heavy chains 1 and 2 increase.
There's this
positive correlation of Maf, which is lower in mice that are losing
weight and higher in mice that are gaining weight, and that corresponds
to the reduction. And there's also, sorry, a correlation with Maf
expression. So Maf and myosin heavy chain 4 expression are correlated.
And if we look at RNA scope and we look at Maf expression, fibers that
express Maf are expressing myosin heavy chain 4, that mature
myosin. And fibers that have lost Maf
are expressing myosin heavy chain 2.
And so you can see it's a pretty robust increase in myosin heavy chain 2,
so a pretty robust change in cell identity.
Myosin heavy chain 1 is also upregulated.
So interestingly, this disturbance of muscle identity is actually
heterogeneous, and it's distinct from that inflammatory and
dysmetabolic cachexia gene program that I have been
alluding to. So overall, if you look at all the myonuclei, there's a loss
of this differentiation gene signature and a gain in what we
call the cachexia gene signature, and these are just literally the top 100 genes
that are changed in skeletal muscle in 22 models of
cancer cachexia. And you can see that these programs are not overlapping.
So there's some intersection between these.
And so this is actually an interesting sidelight.
It is not every myonucleus that is
acquiring these cachexia genes or losing the differentiated gene
program, that these seem to be distinct, at least in this early stage
of cachexia, and maybe they're regulated by
different pathways. And if we look at people, we see
something similar. So the analogous myosin heavy chain in humans
is myosin heavy chain 7. That's reduced in patients
with pancreatic cancer. And you can see that there is a separation of gene
expression of the mature myosin and myosin heavy chains 1 and 2.
And the cachexia genes expression is non-overlapping with
those differentiation phenotype.
However, in severe cachexia, you actually see that there's a trade-off between this
differentiation gene score and the cachexia gene score, such that
if there's more cachexia, there's a less differentiated
transcriptome.
So that's true not only in the muscle.
It turns out it is true in the adipose as well.
And we've known as a field that the adipose microenvironment changes quite a
lot in cachexia. You can see that by simple H&E or Masson's
trichrome. The adipocytes get smaller
through lipolysis. There's remodeling of the
microenvironment. There's a greater fibrosis.
There's an influx and activation of immune cells.
And what we actually observed is also we had occult micrometastases in our
adipose fat pads. But removing those from the
calculation, we have a decrease in adipocytes and a decrease in these
mesenchymal stem cells or adipocyte progenitor cells.
And overall, the picture that we get is that there's actually a dedifferentiation
of the adipocytes as well. And so adipocytes are able to revert back
to a fibroblast stem cell-like phenotype in conditions of
wound healing, and we see that happen systemically in our pancreatic
cancer cachexia model. So we have a loss of genes that
designate a mature adipocyte, including the lineage-specific transcription
factor PPAR gamma. And we have a modulation of these differentiated
adipocytes, particularly a gain of this secretory subset
of adipocytes that we only see in cancer.
This is not just local to tumors that are adipose that might have a
micrometastasis like the visceral fat, but we also observe
the same in the subcutaneous fat. So it's happening distant from the tumor as well.
And we actually did lineage tracing experiments.
So these are mice that express GFAP and mCherry only
in adipocytes through use of an adiponectin Cre
promoter. And you can see that these are perilipin positive.
These are the sham controls. And in the mice with pancreatic cancer,
you can see that they actually retain their
GFP markers, but they develop alpha smooth muscle active
expression
and expression of ICAM. So they're taking on
mesenchymal-like markers while retaining
their markedmarkings of having been an
adipocyte. And that's also clear here in the inguinal fat, where the mice are
still expressing mCherry and GFP but have taken on expression
of ICAM and alpha smooth muscle actin.
So adipocytes are dedifferentiating in this inguinal
fat, which is quite distant from the tumor.
And moreover, if we look at dermal fat, we see the same.
So,
pancreatic cancer is inducing this systemic response to tumor
that's reverting the differentiated phenotype in these adipocytes.
And we see some other changes in the adipocyte progenitor cells as well, but
just for simplicity today, we're actually now interrogating
19 people. We're making an atlas of single cell nucleus
RNA-seq atlas in 19 people for adipose muscle
and tumor. And we see the appearance of these adipocyte low phenotype,
myofibroblast high
adipocyte-like cells in patients with pancreatic
cancer cachexia as well.
And finally, if the tumor is
reprogramming the host, it seems like the host
niche is reprogramming the tumor.
And I give you this example that's
actually supported in the literature, that if you co-culture
pancreatic tumor cells with adipocytes, they mutually
dedifferentiate each other. And we know that if we look at the primary tumor
and we compare it to one of these micrometastases, and we look by single
nucleus RNA-seq, that these adipose pancreatic cancer cells
show a much more aggressive phenotype.
And so they are more basal-like. They also express some classical type
markers. They take on expression of these unfavorable
prognostic markers and are losing favorable prognostic markers.
And then if we look at the top six of these prognostic markers, you can
see they're actually pretty dramatically increased in these
adipocyte resident pancreatic cancer cells.
And each of these is associated with a much worse prognosis
when their expression is higher in people's primary
tumors.
So it makes us think that maybe we need to rethink
this cachexia paradigm,
that in addition to this condition of inflammation, where we
see both immune cell infiltrate into the peripheral tissues, and this is very
well documented in muscle in particular, and
activation of these intrinsic inflammation pathways and the ones that we've studied
most have been STAT3 and NF-kappa B, and others have studied
MyD88 pathways. In addition to that tissue level
inflammation,
and the dysmetabolism, the suppression of protein synthesis,
suppression of fatty acid synthesis, increased protein degradation,
and increased lipolysis, and what we haven't talked about today
is this inhibition of metabolism writ large in
terms of reduction in oxidative phosphorylation.
There's also this background program of cell identity regression
that's induced by the tumor on the peripheral cells.
This leads to a loss or is manifested as a loss of
lineage-specific transcription factors.
And then you get these trajectories of dedifferentiation.
And so not only do you get atrophic muscle, you get identity
regressed muscle. Not only do you get these small adipocytes that
are losing their lipid droplets, they're actually reverting to a much more
stem-like state. And in addition, it's altogether possible that
if that's happening in the adipose to the tumor, if the tumor is
becoming more aggressive because of its contact with or feeding
on the adipocytes, that that could be happening in the primary
tumor in a host that's wasting. So it
suggests that maybe that phenotype that we see of
patients with cachexia who are resistant to chemotherapy, who have
poor surgical outcomes, who are completely resistant to immunotherapy,
that that host biology, the cachexia itself, could serve as not just
a biomarker of treatment resistance, but as potentially a mechanism of
treatment resistance. And I say the evidence for this is that if we can spare
the muscle, we can actually reduce tumor growth.
And we have evidence from that from the field in at least two genetic
models and one from our own, and evidence that
Victoria presented today in mice.
So I'll leave you with that last thought that
I hope you've taken away from this, that our mouse models are reasonable models
of what's happening in patients, and that we should expand our thinking about
cachexia to go beyond
immunometabolism to include these questions about cell
state and cell identity. Thank you.
Maybe I can ask a question. It might be rather stupid, but
when you're looking at the muscle, that's extremely interesting, I guess, the
differentiation programs. But of course, there's satellite cells and things like
that there. Do you have any information or insight as to
how they may be responding, and can you rescue if you
genetically manipulate the satellite cells?
Yes, that's actually a really great question.
So work from Dennis Guttridge and Paolo Castelli have both
shown that myogenesis is actually repressed in cachexia.
So satellite cells are present. To some degree, they can even be
activated, and you even get an accumulation of myoblasts, but they never actually
contribute to the myofiber. So you don't get nuclear accretion, and you
don't get a sparing of muscle. And Dennis
has linked that to the NF-kappa B pathway and
has shown that if you inhibit NF-kappa B in satellite cells, that they can
adhere to the muscle fiber, and you get somewhat of a sparing.
And we've connected that to some other morphogenetic pathways.
But generally speaking, your satellite cells in cachexia, at least in mouse models,
are suppressed. And we actually see no evidence in our single-cell data that
they're activated or changed or that there's any regeneration at all....
happening in cachexia.
It's a great question. Thank you.
Thanks very much for the awesome talk.
I was really excited to see you
trying to make measurements in human patients with cachexia, both
to measure against the mice and to evaluate the fidelity of the
mice. And my question actually has to do
with therapy. So sometimes we can study
cachexia in the treatment-naive setting, and when we're doing that,
we're basically seeing the natural evolution of the pathology.
But unfortunately, a lot of patients,
for us unfortunately, a lot of patients receive therapy, which can
confound
the measurements we're making about them.
So I'm asking you kind of an open-ended question, but I wonder if you have any
thoughts about both the role of therapy in
changing the trajectory of cachexia and actually, more
specifically, sort of the right measurements to make in patients
who both are experiencing physiologic changes from their disease,
but also from therapy itself.
Well, that's a great question. And we've invested a fair amount of time in
trying to develop better preclinical models.
And so for our pancreatic cancer model, we've also included treatment.
So we have done gemcitabine, nab-paclitaxel, paclitaxel.
That turns out to not cause its own cachexia and actually seems to be
protective. There might be a protective mechanism in there.
Folfirinox, folfiri particularly, seems to exacerbate
cachexia, and we're looking at RAS inhibitors now.
So we definitely need to include them in our models, and it's definitely likely
true that different chemotherapy regimens, and others have shown this as well, like
targeted therapies,
are actually promoting cachexia and muscle loss.
But there might be combinations of therapies that are both anti-tumor
and anti-cachexia, and we think that might be the sweet spot.
All right. Thank you.
Thank you for the question.
Hi. Brilliant talk. Thank you.
In your pancreas models, particularly on mouse, can you
say what was the relationship between the presence of metastasis and the
development of the cachexia?
So,
generally speaking, in people,
people with metastases are much more likely to have cachexia.
In mouse models, that's also true.
So if people have developed, Sornali Acharya, for example,
multiple mouse models of metastasis and shown that the
cachexia is worse in the metastatic models, and in her case, she saw that it was
driven by ZFP14 upregulation. She didn't have to make
a metastatic model of pancreatic cancer to see that
ZFP14-dependent cachexia. And so there's something about pancreatic
cancer that already behaves like a metastatic model.
In our particular models, we can actually use micro CT, and we can follow
these tumors, the primary, and the metastases.
And we found that our model actually metastasizes really aggressively to the
liver.
But we actually aren't able to make a correlation between the
presence of metastases and the degree of cachexia, and that turns
out to be true when we look at people with pancreatic cancer as well.
So in a collaboration with Ina Chen, and Julia Johansson, and
Sidsel Lenhard, and BioBank, which is a
biorepository in Denmark,
people who arrive for a diagnosis of pancreatic
cancer with
early-stage disease,
have about 71% of them have cachexia, and that's about the same for
people who have advanced metastatic disease.
So pancreatic cancer behaves as if it's
metastatic with respect to cachexia presentation.
That's a very long answer, but
-
Thank you
... thank you for the question.
Thank you, Teresa. I have a question regarding the adipose tissue.
So do you see induction for UCP1
in the adipose tissue?
Absolutely.
Do you see induction for UCP1 in the adipose tissue?
And also regarding the morphology of the
adipose tissue. So you showed us that there's a change in the morphology.
Do you think what is happening is a browning of the adipose tissue?
No, I don't. Actually, in our model, there's definitely not browning, and
it's definitely model dependent in mice, and it's a very hot topic of debate in the
cachexia field.
There's certainly particular PTH/RP-dependent models in mice.
There's a lot of adipose browning and
mechanisms, I'm sure that you'll tell us about, that contribute to muscle wasting
with adipose browning.
We actually don't see any markers of browning activated in our
models,
not histological and not molecular.
And we don't see it in the transcriptomes from our patients.
And when people have looked very carefully in patients, they have a very hard time
seeing any activation of browning or browning of adipose.
That's not to say it doesn't happen, but people have been looking
at least across disease states and have a hard time observing that.
Thank you for the question.
I have a question, Teresa. So I think your model in thinking
about
dedifferentiation or misdifferentiation of target tissues, including fat
and muscle, is really interesting.
Did you try and compare these tissues in terms of wound
responses? How similar are they? Are we looking at the wound
response
systemically as we already think about the tumor as a wound
itself? Does it spread? Is that the idea, and how does it
compare?
Yeah, absolutely. That's sometimes how I end my
talks, that I think that indeed, a tumor is a non-healing
wound, and your body is making a response to that wound, and the
wound
never resolves. But you go through all of those wound-healing
stages, inflammation, changes in metabolism,
dedifferentiation, which happens in all epithelial cell types prior to
healing.But because the tumor is not
removed, the wound is never relieved.
I think the tissues get stuck in this
wound-healing cycle, and there is no resolution.
Okay.
All right. Well, thank you so much.
So our next speaker is
Dr. Muhannad Abu-Ramalah
from Dana-Farber.
Okay. First of all, I want to thank the organizers and Teresa for the
invitation. Today, I'm going to tell you about the relation
between VHL loss and cachexia in kidney cancer.
So, first of all, kidney cancer,
worldwide, there's about half a million cases every year.
Among them, there is 180,000 deaths.
The main form of kidney cancer is clear cell renal cell carcinoma,
ccRCC.
And in around 85% of
the ccRCC cases, there is one driver
for the tumorigenesis, which is actually the loss of the tumor
suppressor called von Hippel-Lindau tumor suppressor, or VHL.
So it will be
mutated, deleted, or hypermethylated.
So what is VHL doing? So VHL is a part of the
E3 ligase complex.
It's a subunit actually that recognizes the hypoxia-inducible factor
in normoxic conditions, in normal tissues, leading to its
ubiquitination and then proteasomal degradation.
Once VHL is lost or mutated,
actually, HIF2 accumulates in the kidney cancer cells,
leading to tumorigenesis.
Regarding cachexia,
it's been reported that 35% of RCC patients actually
develop cachexia, but we never know what is the reason for cachexia in those
patients.
Fortunately, HIF2 is actually druggable.
So HIF is a transcription factor. In order to be
activated, it needs to heterodimerize
with its partner, ARNT, and
then bind to the HIF response elements, activate the gene transcription
for
genes involved in angiogenesis and proliferation.
There is a specific molecule, allosteric inhibitor, called
belzutifan. It's actually binding specifically to the HIF-2
alpha,
to the small bucket, and prevent its interaction with ARNT, and so
it stops all the gene activation of this
protein.
Belzutifan is already now FDA-approved for
VHL-associated and advanced ccRCC.
So how we get ended studying cachexia in the Kaelin
lab. Actually,
it happened accidentally.
While we was studying the tumorigenesis of a
ccRCC cell line called OSRC2 cells,
we noticed, actually, once we implanted those
cells in the mice, that the mice, once we treated them with a
vehicle compound, they start actually wasting, losing body
weight,
and die because of cachexia. However, once we treated those mice with a
HIF-2 alpha inhibitor,
this is the pre-clinical compound, BT-2399,
we found that those mice actually maintain their body weight and
survive until the end of the experiment.
And this phenotype was actually independent from the tumor size.
This actually led us to think that maybe there is something secreted from
those cells and caused the cachexia in those mice.
To find this secreted factor, we used a PIRA
system,
in which we infected the OSRC2 cells with the
PIRA, with the ER tag that's going to localize
this
PIRA specifically to the endoplasmic reticulum.
So once we add biotin, PIRA is going to biotinylate it, all
the proteins pass through the ER and secreted to the
extracellular
environment.
So what we did, actually,
we
took the OSRC2 cells, the cells that cause cachexia,
and another cell line called 786O cells, another
ccRCC cell line that does not cause cachexia.
We treated the cells with
or without the HIF-2 alpha inhibitor.
We collected the media, concentrated, then performed a
streptavidin pull down, and did a mass spec.
And because we are in the educational session, so
this experiment could be really noisy.
So in order to
eliminate all the false
positive, we had a lot of negative controls, including the parental cells
in all the conditions that we have for the
PIRA cells.
And we found, actually, that
there is a number of secreted protein that
only down-regulated in the OSRC2 cells but not in
the 786O cells. Among them, actually, there is the
PTHrB,
which encoded by the gene called PTHLH,
parathyroid hormone-related protein.
It's well-known in the cachexia field, and it's reported to cause cachexia
in lung cancer model, colorectal, and
pancreatic cancer models.
And it's also reported to be correlated with
hypercalcemia in kidney cancer patients.
So you could see here, like other
hot-Targets in cachexia like IL-6 and GDF15.
However, in our preliminary
validation, PTHrP is the one that stood.
So then we wanted to ask if PTHrP,
PTHLH, the gene that coded PTHrP, is a target for HIF2,
since HIF2 is a transcription factor.
So we performed a ChIP-seq, and we found that HIF2
alpha actually binds to the promoter of the PTHLH.
We also performed RNA-seq and PRO-seq.
We showed that HIF2 regulate the transcription
of the PTHLH. We performed Ribo-seq, and we showed that
HIF2 actually control the translation of the
PTHLH.
Then we ask if the PTHLH actually is necessary for the
cachexia phenotype. To do this, we deleted
PTHLH
in the OSCC2 cells and then implanted those cells again in the
mice. And as you can see here, only the mice with the
SG negative actually developed cachexia
and died because of body wasting. However, the
mice with the PTHLH knockout cells maintained their body
weight
and lived through all the experiments.
This
result actually was coupled with the calcium levels.
So as I mentioned, PTHrP is reported to cause hypercalcemia in kidney
cancer patients, and only mice with the SG negative develop
hypercalcemia.
Most importantly, this phenotype is independent from the
tumor size.
Then we wanted to ask if the phenotype that we see actually is on
target,
and it's happened specifically because of the PTHLH.
To do so,
we took the PTHLH knockout cells and
then infected them with doxycycline, induced
PTHLH cDNA that actually resistant to the SG
PTHLH.
We took the cells, implanted them in the mice, and then
fed the mice with normal chow diet or with dox
diet. And as you can see here, the mice fed with the normal
chow diet maintained their body weight through all the experiments
and survived.
However, once we fed the mice with the dox, they started
actually to develop cachexia four weeks after
start feeding them with dox. And once we took the dox
off, they re-maintain their body weight,
and they survived during the experiment.
However, if we keep feeding them with the dox,
they actually keep losing their body weight and die because of the
cachexia.
This result also coupled with the calcium levels.
As you can see here, only the mice that fed with dox and has the
PTHLH,
developed hypercalcemia. And again, this phenotype was
independent from the tumor size.
Then we wanted to ask if the PTHLH is
sufficient actually to induce cachexia and hypercalcemia in those
mice.
So we infected, we took a 7860
cells, another CCRCC cell line that does not cause cachexia.
We infected the cells with empty vector or with PTHLH
that actually regulated by doxycycline.
And
we put the cells in the mice and then waited until the tumor
established, and then we fed the mice with
dox or we keep them in normal chow diet.
And as you can see here, only mice fed with
dox and has the PTHLH vector actually
developed cachexia
and died because of body wasting.
Again, this phenotype was coupled with the induction of the
hypercalcemia, only with the mice that has
PTHLH and
has cells with the PTHLH
and treated with the dox diet. Again, this phenotype is
independent from the tumor size.
Okay, this is nice. This is all in preclinical models
and in vitro. What is happening in the patients?
I think this is the most important questions.
So,
fortunately, in Dana-Farber, a clinical trial for
bisetufan, the HIF-2 alpha inhibitor, has been done.
So we looked retrospectively to the data of the patients,
and we took the plasma of the patients and looked for
PTHrP levels in those plasma samples.
First of all, we look at the coherent, of the patients.
We look at the pretreatment levels,
and we found that actually PTHrP is actually
elevated in the RCC patients compared
to the
controls.
And we could see that there is a positive correlation in calcium level
between PTHrP levels and
calcium in those patients. And once we stratify
the patients for PTHrP levels,
low or high, we could see clear correlation between high
PTHrP levels and reduce in the muscle mass.
So what is happening once we treat those patients with the
bisetufan, with the HIF-2 alpha inhibitor?
As we can see here, the treatment of the HIF-2 alpha inhibitor was,
with the bisetufan, the HIF-2 alpha inhibitor, was able to reduce the
PTHrP levels.
As a control, we used another two groups of patients
treated with immune checkpoint inhibitors or with a
VEGF-TK inhibitor, and we
only could see the decrease in the PTHrP only with the
HIF-2alpha inhibitor
group.
Also, the treatment with the belzutifan is able to improve the
calcium levels, decrease the calcium level only in the
HIF-2alpha inhibitor-treated group, and also it's led
to increase in the body mass index.
You could see here a very low P value with the
VEGF-TK inhibitor, but this
drug actually decreased the body mass index of the patients.
Interestingly, this phenotype is actually independent from the
tumor
burden. As you can see here, the HIF-2alpha inhibitor is
able to decrease the level of the PTHrP in
stable disease patients also.
So this is one HIF-2alpha inhibitor.
We actually was a little bit
more lucky to connect with another company,
it's called Niken Therapeutics. This company was trying to
develop another HIF-2alpha inhibitor.
So
we asked the same question for this company, that, "How would you like to
share their data with us?"
And their compound called NKT2152,
and as you can see here, the treatment with this
second HIF-2alpha inhibitor is able to decrease the PTHrP levels
only after one week of treatment.
They did also longitudinal study for
41 weeks, and as long as those patients treated with the
HIF-2alpha inhibitor, PTHrP levels kept
low.
We looked at the cohort, the pretreatment cohort,
and actually, we stratified the cohort according to the PTHrP
levels, to the low or medium or
high. And as we can see here, there is a clear
correlation between high PTHrP level
and low body weight. The same for
calcium level. Once PTHrP is high, higher we see
more...
So we see higher levels of calcium in the serum of those
patients.
The treatment with the
HIF-2alpha inhibitor, the second HIF-2alpha inhibitor, is actually able
to decrease calcium level,
especially in the middle and the
high PTHrP groups.
Also,
the treatment with the HIF-2alpha inhibitor, NKT, is able to
increase the body weight
of the patients in
middle and high PTHrP groups.
Again, this phenotype is actually independent from
tumor response. As we can see here, that in both
non-responding and responding patients, there is an
increase and enhancement in body weight once those patients
treated with a HIF-2alpha inhibitor.
So our working model
is,
in kidney cancer, once VHL is deleted or
mutated or hypermethylated, HIF-2alpha actually is
accumulated, binds to its heterodimer partner,
ARNT, activate the transcription of PTHLH,
leading to more secretion of the PTHrP to the bloodstream,
leading to the decrease in body weight and to hypercalcemia.
And we could rescue this phenotype in preclinical model in mice.
Also, we can see the same effect in the patients once we
treated with a HIF-2alpha inhibitor,
whether it's belzutifan or the NKT2152.
Finally, I want to thank
my mentor, my lab, Kaelin lab, my mentor, Bill Kaelin, for his
support during this project. Although we don't work in cachexia in
our lab, but he was very supportive in doing all those assays.
All the collaborators,
Jason Petry
who helped us in characterization of the cachexia model,
Steve Carr from the Prot for the proteomics,
Kai Inamoto for all the analysis for different kind of cancers,
Tony Schwery lab for their help in the
clinical data, and Niken Therapeutics for
sharing
their data about the other HIF-2alpha inhibitor.
For sure, for the patients and families, for participating in all those
clinical trials. And thank you for listening.
Questions?
Young Choi from Northwestern.
Yeah, great talk. Thank you.
Thanks.
So
one question is, definitely cachexia is a prognostic factor for overall
survival. So it was great that you were able to
explore the clinical trial data for both agents.
We use belzutifan in clinic, and it has other side effect,
but then it was great to see how it did affect the weight
changes. So did it actually translate into the survival
difference among patients who actually had
that
preventing cachexia effect? And
it was independent of tumor response.
So, in groups that responded or not responded, did
you look at both groups and see if this drug had...
Well, I guess it's a randomized trial, so you could still look into-
... groups that had impact on overall survival,
or not in both trials. Have you looked into it?
Yeah, that's a very good question, actually.
So belzutifan is approved to treat advanced
RCC.
So in
the other two group, the immuno checkpoint and the
VEGF-A TK inhibitor, so those two drugs
are first line. Belzutifan is always second or
third line. So those patients actually, mostly they
have stage four
kidney cancer. And once we
looked at the survival, so we didn't
see much improvement in the survival, but we see
much more improvement in the body weight and
the calcium levels. I think this
is the caveat of this study, and this
question actually encouraging us to do a prospective
study just to design and treat the patients with belzutifan and see what is
the effect. But yeah, this is one caveat for this study.
All right. Thank you.
Yeah, you're welcome.
Thank you very much. That's very interesting and very convincing, but we didn't
have any mechanistic understanding of how is PTHrP
interfering with cachexia. Maybe because I don't know about that field, but do we
know enough about PTHrP role and how exactly does it
interfere?
Yeah, that's a very good question.
So there's multiple papers
from Russ Spiegelman lab, and there is one recent paper
from Jason Petrace from UMass showing the downstream effect for
PTHrP. So it's mainly binding
to PTHR
one receptor in the adipose tissue, actually, and
cause lipolysis,
and it's caused also browning and induction of UCP1.
So this is one mechanism. It also binds to the muscles and cause
body muscle wasting. So there is two mechanism, but first,
it's PTHrP cause
browning in the adipose tissue.
So was the animals when they gain weight, was it mostly fat or
muscle or both?
Okay. So
I think I will answer it in the other way, once they losing weight.
Okay.
So, first of all, the
first thing what is
happened, actually, they lose fat.
So first they lose fat, and then they start losing muscles.
Okay.
It's very interesting, actually, once we started to observe this phenotype.
Once I opened the mice, after they developed the cachexia, there
is no fat in the mice. No fat at all. And then,
I still see the muscles, but once we did
more depth analysis, we see also muscle
wasting, but we see way more fat
wasting.
Hi, thank you for a very nice talk. Actually, my question was already
partially answered by the previous question.
Yeah.
So I was wondering whether, because here you've showed that
PTHrP expression modulates,
so body weight and muscle mass, but do you know whether the opposite is true?
Because I'm thinking about the obesity paradox in ccRCC, and whether
the baseline weight of the patient can also influence the extent to which
PTHrP might be expressed, in their tumors.
Like you mean, could we-
Is the modulation bidirectional or unidirectional? If you know what I mean.
Like could we reverse the phenotype?
Yes. In a way.
Yes. We could reverse the phenotype.
So
actually in those experiments, at least in the preclinical experiments
that we performed, the mice losing actually 10 to 15%
of their body weight, so they actually developed cachexia, and
then we treated them with a HF2A inhibitor, and that's enough actually to regain
the body weight. So we able to
reverse the phenotype. However, we didn't try to treat
the severe cachectic mice, which
are very sick.
In the design of the experiment, we waited until they lost
10 to 15%, and then we treated with the HF2A inhibitor.
We could see very clear
increase in the body weight.
And do you think that diet modulation can reverse the phenotype or not?
The what?
The diet modulation of the mice.
The diet modulation?
I'm not sure about that. We didn't do this experiment.
Mm-hmm.
But once the mice actually started to develop cachexia, they become
very weak, actually. We tried to put some soft
diet for the mice, but-
Mm-hmm.
They were not eating.
They are not eating or-
Okay.
I think it's not only they are not eating, it's
beyond the appetite.
Yeah.
They just burning their fats, actually.
Okay. And then final point, do you know whether PTHrP expression is in
any way associated with necrosis within the tumors?
So there is a previous reported showing PTHrP
that has oncogenic
function in RCC. However, in our hands, we
didn't notice that.
Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah, you're welcome. Thanks.
Those were really intriguing questions.
I wondered, thinking about the hierarchies of factors that
cause cachexia, did you look in the patients and in the mice at other
factors like GDF15 and IL6 and that sort of thing?
Yeah. So, thanks for this question. Yeah, that's a very important question.
So, we looked at GDF15. We didn't see any
difference in GDF15 before or after treatment with the
HF2A inhibitor, and we compared the healthy group with
the RCC. There is no induction. We looked for IL6
also. The same, we didn't see any induction there.
But yeah, in the patients, we looked in the patients and in the
mouse actually, before and after treatment with HF2A inhibitor.
We did not see a different... We looked actually at IL6
and at the soluble receptor of IL6 to be sure that
we are looking at the right things. But we didn't see any difference there.
Maybe I can just ask a question because I'm just interested, and also
I'm thinking about osteoporosis and PTHP,
this kind of treatments, and if there's anything you can extract from that kind
of data. And cachexia, is that something you've looked at?
Yeah. Actually, we didn't look at the bones, at osteoporosis, but this is
very valid point because we see the hypercalcemia.
Where does the calcium come from?
Yeah.
For sure come from the bones.
So there is other models, the head and neck carcinoma models in which people showed
that PTHrB induce
osteoporosis, and this is what actually cause to the hypercalcemia.
But we didn't look at that actually. Yeah.
And a beautiful study from the molecular all the way to real life.
Yeah.
Well, thank you.
Mary.
Can I ask one more question? Thank you. Thank you for a wonderful talk.
I don't have a question, actually, but you've made me think of something, and for
clinicians and non-clinicians in the room, it might be relevant.
But
PTHr related peptide is something that nephrologists
typically will look for in chronic kidney disease and certainly
in patients on dialysis. And you've made me think of perhaps could it be a
mechanism that drives cachexia in end-stage renal failure.
Although I'm often told, my husband is a nephrologist, and he says, "No, we don't
know why they get cachexia, but it might be that it's reduced clearance
because they have kidney failure." But maybe thinking about a blood
test, those thresholds for raised
PTHRP might be some indication of subsequent
cachexia, even in the renal failure field, potentially.
And you could access large patient populations because they bank those bloods and
results.
Yeah. That's a very good point. Yeah. Thank you so much.
Actually, we had this worry about the renal failure.
We worried that the reviewers, once we submitted the paper, they're going to told
us that the phenotype that you see because of the renal failure,
because we used orthotopic models, so we injected the cells in the kidney,
and then we use also subcutaneous models
for the same
cells, and we still see the phenotype. But yeah, this is a very valid point.
Well, thank you, everyone. Thank you for all the great questions.
And if you'd like, there's another cachexia session at twelve
o'clock,
chaired by Marcus Gonsalves in, I think, room 15.
What's the cause of death?
Is it PE?
Pulmonary embolism, basically, blood clots.
Oh, we didn't have that. So these mice become
very, very small.
Of course.
And very sick. They even cannot move to get their food.
So I'm just-
Yeah.
I'm from Syria, but I was attending in Sydney.
Oh, really?
The overriding theme is people are dying from metastatic
disease. Okay?
No, no.
But
if
this is a cachexia, which basically means tissue wasting, tissue is every
tissue. So if you start to lose the endothelial cells-
Mm-hmm.
The blood vessels-
Yeah.
Then you expose collagen to the blood.
Bye. We'll see you around. Thank you for a great talk.
See you